I'm a little bit afraid are people
afraid of you now because of this show
and they should be you might get a
finger missing in a minute I have
moments I mean we're here celebrating
this unbelievable show I blew through
the most recent season in about a day
when you saw some of that stuff when you
were first reading that script what was
going through your mind shocked or nope
this feels on point well God all of
those things you know it's a wonderful
juicy character but in many ways his
he's a pathetic monster and there's
quite a few out in the real world and so
I love getting to grips with that kind
of psyche and but the tables will turn
I'm sure do you get a little bit in a
dark place by playing them I mean you
have to do some crazy stuff how do you
lighten things up or how do you survive
playing this character well we have a
wonderful cast like a family and we all
get on incredibly well and have a really
good time a lot of joking in between
takes but it is it's it's sensitive
subject matter and we feel sort of I
think I could speak for the others to
say that there's a responsibility to
fulfill because we caught the show it's
called a kind of zeitgeist in a way of a
certain movement and so there's always
that kind of sense of warning to honor
that well it's interesting because when
the new season came out a lot of the
reaction was oh wow it's weird how much
this is reflecting the real world a
little bit right now how did you guys
react when you heard how people were
receiving it and how do you feel that
the show is hitting that note well it's
great that it's prescient Margaret
Atwood's
novel was so prescient all those years
ago part of me thinks how our writers
must be clairvoyant I don't know how
they timed it so perfectly but I think
they're just on the pulse and all all
the departments are converging at the
right time 2020 nominations tonight and
it are you first-time nominee here
tonight I am this is a first for me
how you feeling kind of elated I'm
really excited I'm very happy to be here
and just the nomination alone is
are you somebody who plans the speech
out or doing it oh no no I have no plans
whatsoever to make the speech and how
does the cast feel about all these
nominations and how will you celebrate
any wins afterwards tonight hit the
dance floor eat a burger what are you
guys gonna do well we're celebrating now
I mean just to get the nominations is a
huge achievement and yeah throw a couple
of drinks tonight in there and it'll be
wild first I have to ask because I blew
through the season so quickly what do
you want to see happen next season that
ending was unbelievable if you had some
dream plot points what do you want to
see go down well it's all sort of blown
up at the end which is great it means
that it can go anywhere but I think now
is a time for some kind of uprising so
hold on to your seats I think something
big is gonna happen because you think
Alfred went back again she went back
there again yeah but she's a mother I
mean I have kids and I get that I really
get that need to go back in especially a
daughter you know what they do so and
she's sort of sacrificing herself I
think I get it I get why she's gone in
will we see her back in their house
again what do you think I think that's
almost impossible that's my hunch in
terms of how the commander was left but
I've got a few words to say to her for
sure I mean do you know anything
anything you can tease for us or is it
still all of them here
whatever I say is completely made up I
have no idea so I could tease but I'd be
probably way off we also have to ask you
by the way about to be I think here's
the 20th anniversary of Shakespeare in
Love I mean five years battle I am going
gray rather rapidly it must be 20 years
we love that movie do you ever still
talk to Gwyneth and how fondly do you
remember that will experience I've
worked with her a few times afterwards
and we get on really well and I love her
very much and we're good friends
although I don't really catch up much
you know she's got her goob site she can
do it just to give you the health tips
you ever get on my wife loves yeah she's
a big fan
yeah all right well if you could
describe the cast feelings tonight one
word what is it related pretty much okay
and you're gonna get season three for us
right away we're gonna have it nobody
has to wait or anything just roll with
it straightaway if you like
[Music]